he's the head coach of the tennessee
titans mike grebel back here on the
program how are you coach
honey how are you how are you buddy
we're on a peacock man yes we're the
advertisement
we are we are on peacock we're on there
i'm over caffeinated are you a coffee
drinker
mike do you drink coffee huge huge how
many cups a day what do you got
what are you uh as many as they'll give
me i like that uh
that triple americano okay uh
from our wonderful people at the
hillsborough pike starbucks
okay and uh they they are amazing i love
seeing them
every morning uh with a smile on their
face i do get pre-order i figure out
that pre-order you know i mean you go to
the app
leave the house you walk in one time it
was raining
and cassie actually brought the coffee
out to my car
i i was like i was that that won me over
right there of course
absolutely how badly did they botch your
last name when they spell it or
just the first thing how badly
well you know they they they know me
here after three years they
at least got my you know last name
figured out music coach mike on the
on the top coach mike it feels like home
there my bad
of course feels like home fantastic um
yeah i've gotten
several cups at me today so i'm feeling
good um
so uh how how are things what what where
are you now
are you you're you're through mini camps
and stuff like that and yeah we finished
up today yep
players are um you know working their
way out you know i mean on that last day
at mini camp
you know you come in and you have a
squad meeting at 8 30 and
you ask a show of hands of how many uh
how many of those guys left their cars
running in the parking lot and about
75 hands go up so i said
i guess we'll make this short and sweet
right uh you know they kind of know the
drill
um you know we said hey when we're not
going bowling we're not going to go
skeet shooting we're not going to top
golf uh those are things that you guys
have fun i have fun watching you guys
run so we're gonna go outside and run
and you guys are free to leave and i had
fun and i enjoyed myself watching them
run so
and they then they took off what do you
enjoy watching them run i wonder
what what what enjoy i like that i like
watching them see what kind of condition
we're and i like
that i enjoy that okay i like it except
why wouldn't you
yeah i mean like i'm i i'm the coach i
get i like watching them
work out let's be honest though
belichick belichick did it to you so
you're passing it on essentially is what
you're saying right did bill do that to
you guys did he do that to you i mean
there's a lot of things you know i mean
there's a lot of things
that i that i do that i learned from my
time in new england and certainly
that that was a great resource for me as
a coach now but
i don't remember us running on the last
day of
many maybe we did i don't even remember
so long ago you blocked it out
[Laughter]
maybe that's maybe that's what you did
so what what what what
what have you picked up from bill do you
ever catch yourself saying something
they're like oh god i've swore myself i
never say anything like that to a player
and now
you're doing that has that ever happened
to you um
yeah you know you get you get into this
mode where like you know it's my fault
you know i mean maybe i didn't make it
clear enough i
you know i didn't do a good enough job
explaining to you that
when it says 12 o'clock on the schedule
that it's lunch
like that's what time lunch is like you
know i mean i i
i that's my fault like i i screwed that
up yeah i mean just
just the over-the-top passive
aggressiveness that we all just
laugh at you're passive-aggressive
when it comes to that is what you're
saying no no i i try not to be you know
i
mean
i want to be you know honest direct
you know and and be you know we don't
have a whole lot of time but then it'll
just be like you know i screwed that up
you know i got it
you know that that i i'll i'll do a
better job like
i'll do a better job of explaining what
the expectation wow i didn't expect to
ask you if there's something that
belichick
instilled in you that you're now passing
along that you'd say passive
aggressivity that's a
that was a curveball i mean i just i can
remember bill just being the
sarcasticness
you know i mean yeah the the the
sarcasticness i mean there's a lot of
great things i've learned from bill he's
been a
great mentor you know along with other
coaches but
you know we're we're we're competitors
now you know we
we are going to compete against his team
and he's going to
you know compete against ours now i
guess let me go this one and then we'll
we'll move on to the current here and
now then
uh mike frable if i told you when you
were catching touchdown passes from
brady
in the end zone in uh in in in big
playoff games in the super bowl
that one day you would be the head coach
that would end the brady belichick era
in new england
what would you have said to that mike oh
i i mean yeah how long is it going to be
till i do it i guess i don't know i mean
i always figured i wanted to coach for a
while and
you did you know yeah i mean i think i
grew up and my dad was a coach you know
i mean i grew up on the bench you grew
up sitting behind the bench
you know i mean in high school you know
basketball gyms and
catching my dad's sport coat as he threw
it off in the middle of first quarter
and it
wrapped around my head i was like seven
and you know
this would always determine you know
what kind of mood my dad was in
by how early the sport coke came off and
uh
what what what would you say uh i don't
know if you've had a conversation with
him maybe not but
urban meyer now taking the step into the
world that you have
uh inhabited for quite some time uh as
well as the
hc uh in the nfl how do you think he is
going to
fare in the nfl or any advice that you
would have
for him to go from one step to the next
i don't like drabel i mean urban's a
great coach he's
you know he's proven and he'll he'll
he'll figure out
you know what he wants to do with his
football team and that i learned a lot
from urban and
worked uh for him and with him for
for two years you know and we've talked
and we've had conversations but
you know that's the thing when you're
you're a head coach you have to you know
you figured on there's certain ways you
want to do things that are going to be
different than
you know how other people do it or right
it's different team to team
you know and so that's like parenting
you know you
you kind of figure it out as you go
along and you know make mistakes and
what would you do better
or what would you do differently the
next time
i love it i think you're gonna figure it
out he's been a great coach for a long
time like
parenting that is a great answer mike
frable here on the rich eisen show
okay so let's talk about um uh julio
jones if you don't mind
um what did what have you seen from him
so far
um and uh what boxes did they check that
you already
knew were already checked but i'll just
walk you through that process if you
don't mind walking us through it
you'll hold my hand as we walk through
it yes that'll be nice
well i mean we could interlock in
something so professional i mean i
appreciate his professionalism he's
communicated
you know he traded for him it came in
you know he left he communicated when he
wanted to come back
as far as you know the the voluntary
stuff
he's been engaged in meetings kind of
figuring out how we do things
like i just mentioned you know before
every team is different you know every
team starts practice a different way
every team
does meetings a different way some some
people ask a lot of questions and
you know it's just everything is
different and i think he's been
very open to to learning the way that
we do things and um to been open to
learning what we do and how we do it
so that's that's the biggest thing that
i'm
you know pleased with as a coach you
know and it's interesting that you you
mentioned
communicating being one of the first
things that you mentioned
what do you mean by that what some fans
might be like huh uh
what what about how important that is he
communicated to you
what and that you heard what for him
yeah i mean i think that that's just um
that the battle that we wage is you know
we ask our guys to
to have enough confidence and trust in
us to to communicate things that are
going on
you know outside of football and that's
what we ask of all our players and so
it's like hey i've
got this going on i'm gonna take care of
this uh in atlanta i'm gonna get some
things
cleaned up and you know i'm gonna i'm
gonna be back there on thursday i want
to get back out on the field with with
my teammates as quickly as possible
and um you know that that was just an
early example of what he did and
continue to communicate um
you know there's a lot a lot of things
that go involved with
veteran players and preparing for
practice and what they
you know need to be ready uh for for the
game and for the season and
those are things that you know i try to
draw on my experience as a veteran
player and the communication that i had
you know with the coaches and everybody
else well and and that was a part of the
conversation at least in the media
coach about when julio jones was
seemingly
up for the acquiring that
any team that takes him um will have to
understand he doesn't practice as much
as other younger receivers because of
the amount of practice time that he
either missed in atlanta or
his advancing age despite him being
still a young man
in the real world what what's your
expectation level of
how much you're going to see julio
practice
this fall well we have a plan for we
have a plan for for every individual
on the football team and sometimes that
that plan is different from
player to player sometimes it's the same
um
you know i'm not going to try to
determine what that is right now
you know we'll see how it is when we go
along and what our schedule looks like
there'll be a lot of
players that um you know have different
schedules throughout training camp and
and even into the season and that's our
job and that's my job to
to be able to manage that you know to
make sure that they're
they're doing everything that they can
to to help us on on sunday or whenever
we play
but in terms of uh your your your
uh plan for the season have you had a
conversation with him about that
already has that already been broached
with you and him in terms of the
community
we've had we've had we've had those
conversations but i don't think that
we're
you know ready to to determine what
that's going to look like i'm not going
to try to determine what that looks like
uh from now until september or october
as the season goes long that change you
know i mean i change practice schedules
um routinely throughout the season you
know based on
a lot of factors and when we play and
the health of our football team and
what i think we need what i think is
going to be best for the for the team
did you notice a jolt maybe amongst the
team that uh the front office and you
um whatever your role was in all of this
um uh getting aggressive bringing a
player of julio's caliber
and uh level i mean the the level of
respect that players
have for julio in this league is through
the roof
was there a jolt that you saw on your
team once this trade was
uh was completed and he showed up you
know i don't i don't think we practiced
the ota any better or any worse i mean i
just
you know my message is that we have to
go out and we have to work and
we have to perform um
and that's that's what i love about
football that it doesn't matter that the
draft pick
doesn't matter what your compensation is
it doesn't matter how young or how old
the only thing that matters is what you
do when you're out there you know we've
we've acquired players
on the post draft that have helped us
win we've acquired players through
trades and free agencies
and we don't care how you get here we
just care what you do when you're here
what are you doing now what's the next
few weeks for you you're going to take
some time you're going to travel you
know
yeah i mean i'm just going to try to uh
you know unwind a little bit uh try to
continue to brush up
you know um on our training camp and
what i want to try to get done continue
to work through those things
uh tyler's bringing some buddies home
here on the fourth of july i guess so
okay
from college are gonna play
uh golf in tahoe in the event that's
wonderful
and um hey that'll be it all right
you know what's gonna work did you make
sure you don't put one uh
on somebody's uh deck out there on that
part you know i mean last year there
weren't any spectators so they don't
stop the ball from going out of bounds
right here i hope they have the fairways
lined and so that they'll kick it back
in understood
well done that's why i play golf with
the gallery as a human shield
that's what i do that's it i protect the
outbound come on seriously
what's your what's your what's your
what's your game like though i mean what
do you
what are you piping it's up and down it
is so erratic it's so it's so up and
down
i'm a really good scramble partner i'm a
really
i'm a really good two-man scramble
partner i that it could be great and it
can be
god-awful so if i need you
if i need you in the short stuff um
you know it's it's better if you're if
you're what like you're
approaching on a on a par five is that
what you're saying that's
that's that's where your best get me out
there and i'll try to bomb one out there
but if not like i
i could i could hook it pretty good you
know roll over
rolling hands over a little bit i i have
fun i enjoy it
all right well i'd be remiss if i didn't
before i let you go is there any part of
you and i'm
seriously in the next few weeks that
you're planning on literally what your
place looks like for
vaccinated players and unvaccinated or
not fully vaccinated and that there's a
certain
spot where these guys go and those guys
go is that literally the way that this
is going to go for training camp
right now and how that affects them you
know john and i will handle that with
our ops department and
right you know and our and our trainers
and yeah i felt like we did a great job
last year we'll have to continue down
the same path for
for some of that and whatever it is that
they say that we have to do and whatever
the protocols are
however many weight rooms we need and
however many masks that we need to have
available for players and
however different they need to be that's
what we'll do
and uh that's that's all that's all i
can say
you know i mean we think about it and
we'll be meeting about it throughout the
summer
okay and uh and then you could keep
giving derek henry his workout tips on
how to do push-ups
uh with a lot with with uh resistance
bands and
and and balancing balls right that's
right just stay tuned it'll be back on
instagram that's what i tell them i say
just check instagram find out if derek's
lifting
any weight the 21st century head coach
mike frable thanks for the call greatly
appreciate it okay rach thank you you'd
be well you'd be well thank you
that's mike frable everybody hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here